bonsoir et bienvenue pour le 78 lactu en
ce 2 juillet 2014 il est 18h pour ceux
qui nous rejoignent en direct et voici
donc les titres le préfet fait le point
sur la sécurité publicque dans les
ivelines on retiendra notamment le
nombre de cambriolag en baisse après 2
années de fortes hausse vigilance des
voisins mise en place d'unités
policières spécifiqu explique ce
résultat le Golf National de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline va accueillir à
partir de demain une nouvelle édition de
l'Open les champions sont déjà sur place
vous les entendrez dans un instant à
quoi ressemblera la maison de demain à
Versailles des étudiants livre leur
vision du futur à travers leur maison
solaire le Solar d'cathlon un
rendez-vous international qui se déroule
actuellement à Versailles le directeur
de la compétition Pascal Ray et l'invité
du journal bientôt une piste de ski dans
l'agglomération de 50 ans en nvelin le
refrain est connu depuis 20 ans
plusieurs projets ont été annoncés pour
enfin valoriser la colline d'élencour
située à l'entrée du quartier de la clé
de Saint-Pierre seulement les choses
semblent s'accélérer demain jeudi à 20h
une réunion publiqué prévue à éencour à
l'hôtel de ville afin de présenter
enjeux et faisabilité le groupe local
d'Europe Écologie Les Verts s'oppose à
cette idée il dénonce le cûpt et le
gaspillage d'énergie alors que la
communauté d'agglomération s'est doté
récemment d'un plan énergie clim
les chiffres de la sécurité publique
sont bons en ce qui concerne les 5
premiers mois de cette année à comparé
avec la même période pour 2013 les
cambriolages sont en baisse un point
noir toutefois les vols dit par rus ce
qui vise les personnes âgées plus
particulièrement en forte augmentation
Catherine
zulato la réforme de la police mise en
place dans le département est-elle en
train de porter ses fruits et la réforme
démarré en 2013 a vu une évolution à
compté de janvier 2014 avec une
mutualisation des moyens et des
créations de groupes spécialisés en
matière de lutte contre les stupéfiants
et les cambriolages et les cambriolages
justement depuis le début de l'année ils
sont en baisse dans le département -
13,4 % de janvier à mai 2014 à comparé
au nombre de fait sur la même période en
2013 et les cambriolages d'habitation
principal régressent de leur côté de
25,5 %. si les cambriolagees sont en
diminution les taux d'élucidation sont
en progression sur les 5 premiers mois
de l'année pour les cambriolage ce taux
est de 10,26 % soit 4 points de plus
qu'à la même période de 2013 par contre
deux points noir en matière de sécurité
publique l'augmentation des atteintes
volontaires à l'intégrité physique
progresse de 8,51 % ce sont les coups et
blessures les violences et mauvais
traitement à enfants qui expliqueent en
grande partie cette progression et forte
augmentation des vols dit par rus ce
type de délinquence vise principalement
les personnes âgées ils ont progressé de
près de 45 % sur un an un point aussi
concernant les zones de sécurité
prioritair elles sont trois dans le
département dont une concernant trappp
qui est passée en ZSP en janvier 2014
est difficile donc de dresser un bilan à
Notter une progression du nombre
d'infractions relevé de plus 711 % sur
les 5 premiers mois de 2014 par rapport
à 2013 un travail particulier est
effectué au sein de ces zones de
sécurité prioritaire des groupes dit
miroir se sont réunis pour échanger avec
la population des cellules de
coordination opérationnelle avec
différents partenaires et les
associations sont également sollicitées
bilan complet adressé l'année
prochaine conséquence du rachat par le
fabricant américain d'appareils médicaux
medatronics de son concurrent Covidien
pour près de 43 millions de milliards de
dollars la fermeture du site d'éloncour
Covidien quittera ses locaux en
septembre et son principal prestataire
de service DHL va aussi en faire les
frais les 59 salariés de cette société
de transport et de de logistique vont se
retrouver au chômage ils étaient dans la
rue aujourd'hui pour dénoncer un plan de
sauvegarde de l'emploi qui ne les
satisfait pas ils annoncent une grève
reconductible si la prochaine réunion
avec la direction du 4 juillet ne leur
apporte pas plus de répones DHL
travaille avec Covidien sur é encour
depuis une dizaine
d'années le le le souci c'est que
Covidien et
DHL sont en train de négocier par avocat
interposé donc nous on est pris en éo
entre les deux aujourd'hui donc ce qu'on
demande c'est évidemment le minimum de
ce qui est fait
dans ces situations là et également des
compensations par rapport par rapport à
la perte l'emploi des 59 salariés
aujourd'hui on a des personnes qui sont
sont quand même qui parl de suicide
quand même le dire qui sont pas
présentes aujourd'hui on a des une
population de personnes qui ont plus de
50 ans donc ça va être très compliqué VO
même impossible pour pour elle de
retrouver
unemploi 520 intérimair de moins pour
Peugeot le constructeur automobile il a
annoncé que les missions d'intérim ne
seront pas renouvelées sur l'usine PSA
c'est la conséquence d'une vaste
réorganisation lancée dans ce centre de
production à la rentrée une seule ligne
de montage sera opérationnelle pour
réaliser 208 DS3 et C3 au lieu des deux
chaînes de montage utilisé actuellement
l'Alstom Open de France débute demain
jeudi à Saint-Quentin en Yveline le
parcours de l'Albatros est prêt les
meilleurs joueurs de golf de la planète
sont déjà arrivés sur place Anthony
Resche Olivier Maniscalco ont rencontré
le vainqueur de l'édition 2013 le
nordirlandais grem McDowell et puis le
favori de cette année aussi l'Allemand
Martin keimer côté français 25 joueurs
sur la ligne de départ dont Thomas Levet
vainqueur en
2011 toutes les caméras sont désormais
braquées sur lui après sa finale au
championnat du monde de match play où il
élimina notamment gr mcdoell et son
baptême de l'US Open le statut de Victor
dubisson a changé il est désormais la
tête d'affiche du golf français et
favori pour le titre aguille en cours
oui je sens qu'il y a plus plus
d'attention
forcément avec les résultats que j'ai
fait j'ai fait ces derniers 6
mois mais après ça me met pas pas plus
de pression que ça au contraire je
trouve que c'est bien c'est bien de
d'avoir le public qui qui supporte et
ben je vais après sur ce parcours c'est
tellement difficile je vais je vais
faire de mon mieux en vue de la rider
Cup 2018 quelques évolutions ont été
apporté à l'Albatros en 2014 les Green
sont plus dur et les zones de reuf mieux
taillé en résumé tout pour plaire au jeu
agressif du numéro 1 français il est
vraiment dans un état
extraordinairef là on peut
vraiment dis pas ça parce que c'est le
tourno qui qui se passe en France mais
on peut vraiment comparer les Green à ce
à la qualité et la vitesse d'Augusta
beaucoup de gens disent que les Green
sont mou mais je trouve pas pas si mou
que ça ils sont ils pit juste comme il
faut et là tout est tout est vra
vraiment parfait pour succéder à Thomas
Levet dernier tricolore vainqueur ici en
2011 Victor dubisson n'aura pas le droit
à l'erreur il va entrer dans le vif du
sujet dès ce jeudi avec un premier tour
très attendu en compagnie des ténor Grem
mcdoell et de Martin keer sacré sur
l'Albatros en 2009 l'allemand 11e joueur
mondial visera un 3e titre en 2014 après
son triomp à l'US
Open on quitte le sport pour parler de
logement après ont à peine les examens
terminés les milliers d'étudiants
évelinois partent maintenant à la
recherche de leur logement pour la
rentrée prochaine pour leur donner un
petit coup de pousce un forum était
organisé il y a quelques jours à
l'université de Versailles Saint-Quentin
en Yveline yolè Torz était sur place je
recherche un truc à 100 minutes de la
fac c'est grand pas trop
cher la course au logement a débuté pour
les étudiants en première année de
médecine agas profite de ce forum
organisé par l'Université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin en Yveline pour tenter de
trouver son bonheur un studio aux
alentours de 400 € dans une résidence
universitaire j'ai pas vraiment eu la
possibilité de faire des recherche super
tôt vu que je devais travailler et mes
parents ils avaient pas non plus
beaucoup de disponibilité donc je me
suis pris assez tard au final et j'avais
pas non plus des des explications super
claires sur Internet tout ça
donc étudiant en médecine aussi jourta
de son côté s'est fixé un budget de 500
€ maximum et les recherches semblent
plutôt compliquées je pense que je pense
que cette année c'est un petit peu mal
parti et je vais peut-être rester chez
mes
parents donc il y a la PL qui prend à
peu près 250 € mais derrière si si un
loyer fait 500 € s'il reste 250 à payer
derrière pour payer ces 250 € restant un
petit job en complément lui semble la
meilleure solution j'ai dà un petit peu
tel le terrain à Carrefour qui m'ont qui
m'ont dit probablement peut-être que
peut-être que pour l'année ça le ferait
mais là aussi il faut voir selon
l'emploi du temps de ma fac si c'est
compatible donc on va voir ce forum
logement est aussi l'occasion de
rappeler quelques règles essentielles il
faut être vigilant sur le loyer savoir
si les charges sont nous sont comprises
ou ne sont pas comprise dans ce loyer et
puis vraiment visiter le logement pour
pour s'assurer que tout est conforme à
ce qui avait été convenu par une annonce
établir un état des lieux précis parce
que voilà des fois on n'est pas vigilant
à notre entrée dans les lieux mais
finalement à la sortie du coup ça peut
être après ponctionné sur le dépôt de
garantie laissé par les étudiants ce qui
est vraiment dommage pour plus de
renseignement la DEAL 78 propose des
consultations gratuites et
personnalisées dans tout le
département une fois que ces étudiants
retrouvé leur logement pourquoi pourquoi
ne pas le décorer à la mode des années
70 pour vous inspirer aguille en cours à
l'occasion des 40 ans du quartier du
Pont du routoire un appartement typique
de cette période a été reconstitué
mobilier en plastique couleur orange
petit flashback avec Aurélia debissi et
David
charpentier mobilier gonflable couleurs
et formes improbables pas de doute nous
avons remonté le temps où le plastique
et la bacélite font irruption dans notre
quotidien et révolutionnent même nos
modes de consommation bienvenue dans les
années 70 à l'occasion des 40 ans du
quartier du Pont du routtoir à
guillancour la ville propose à ses
habitants de revivre un moment
d'histoire à travers la reconstitution
partielle d'un appartement de l'époque
dans cet appartement on peut donc
découvrir toutes les pièces qui
contiennent des du mobilier qui donc
caractéristique de ces années-là c'est
plus une évocation des années 70 qu'une
reconstitution
réaliste réalisé grâce aux collections
du musée de la ville de Saint-Quentin en
ivline les visites ont permis aux
nostalgiques de redécouvrir l'esthétique
caractéristique de la fin des 30ente
glorieuses et d'initier les plus jeunes
au tendance
colorée
on a reçu évidemment beaucoup de de
classes de toutes ces écoles de de
guillancour qui ont pu découvrir donc
tout tout ce mobiliier toutes ces formes
ces couleurs qui sont vraiment celles
que de qu'on connu leurs parents voir
leurs grands-parents et euh et donc
cette cette exposition leur a permis
vraiment de
s'initier à cette esthétique et et puis
aussi de de retrouver voilà des le côté
ludique du design de l'époque à la fois
esthétique et pratique il y a des donc
des motifs qui qui sont vraiment très
caractéristique et qui les ont frappé
parfois ces enfants avaient vraiment
envie de de
retrouver de vivre dans cet appartement
euh donc finalement l'esthétique ludique
et
coloré a été vraiment très voilà les a
les a enchanté pour la plupart et ils
étaient très réceptif en tout cas on a
eu de très bons retours puisque les
habitants du quartier ont pu ont eu la
chance de retrouver donc ces archives à
travers les films avec en se retrouvant
parfois même dans ces films des proches
et et donc ça fait partie voilà d'une
histoire l'histoire d'un quartier c'est
l'histoire d'une presque une grande
famille en quelque sorte
de la maison du passé à celle du futur
concevoir et réaliser un habitat
fonctionnel utilisant le soleil comme
seule source d'énergie c'est le principe
du Solar Décathlon qui se déroule depuis
quelques jours maintenant à Versailles
c'est une compétition c'est même un
concours international avec des
universités des grandes écoles nous
avons suivi certains compétiteurs
notamment l'équipe suisse Olivier
Maniscalco Jonathan villman sur place 4e
jour de compétition pour le Solar
d'cathlon de Versailles après avoir
monté leur maison solaire les équipes
sont désormais évaluées par un jury de
spécialistes trois critères ont déjà été
jugés bilan énergétique confort des
maisons et communication autour du
projet une communication que l'équipe
suisse originaire de Lucerne soigne
auprès du public en proposant par
exemple des parasols gratuits aux
visiteurs il faut dire que leur projet
Luc est basé sur le partage trois pièces
composent la maison solaire une privée
avec chambre et salle d'eau une autre
semi-privée avec cuisine et une dernière
où tout le monde peut se rendre c'est
ensuite grâce à une application sur
smartphone et tablette que le tout sera
agencé le but de l'équipe mieux utiliser
l'espace urbain de plus en plus
restreint notre concept c'est de
partager de partager les choses qui qui
on possède de partager la place où on
habite ça vient de de l'histoire alors
on a le le concept de partager dans le
dans le Payson qui habite ensemble qui
travaill ensemble ça s'appelle k shaft
ça c'est pas je sais pas le mot en
français mais on a transformé ce modèle
et on a l'utilise pour nous oui si pour
l'ensemble des équipes les 10 jours de
montage ont été suffisants pour proposer
une maison apte à la compétition la team
parisienne livelb elle n'a toujours pas
terminé son chantier être bâtisseur ça
ne s'improvise pas surtout sans
professionnel pour encadrer le montage
c'est un projet vraiment difficile donc
il fallait gérer tout l'inclination
desortique qu'elle forme la derrière et
donc c'est toujours à contrôler ils sont
plusieurs choses à contrôler on a décalé
de plus en plus il fallait avoir un peu
plus de temps ça c'est sûr parce que
pour un projet de cette dimension là
aussi avec la difficulté de de la
structure qu'on a c'est vraiment pas
beaucoup 10 jours si livelb est
malheureusement déjà hors course pour
une victoire au solar 2014 la France
peut encore compter sur un autre projet
tricolore pour l'instant 5e au
classement les é de Phileas gardent en
effet toutes leur chance mais avec 10
jours restants d'évaluation la route est
encore
longue et à quoi ressemble la maison de
demain pour vous votre habitat du futur
c'est notre question du jour micro
trottoir faudra qu'elle soit autonome en
énergie mais il faudrait quand même
qu'elle reste jolie avec des matériaux
recyclables je pense que les énergies
solaires les énergies tout ça va être
utilisé de mieux en mieux de plus en
plus plus économique aussi déjà mieux
chauffé mais plus économique quoi
l'habitat de demain ben un habitat
résolument orienté écolour et avec
beaucoup moins d'énergie vore que que ce
qu'on peut avoir aujourd'hui plutôt
écologique qui préserve l'environnement
avec des matériaux assez qui qui
réchauffent qui on n pas vraiment besoin
de mettre son chauffage à fond ou autre
peut-être plus de bois plus de bois et
puis bah forcément toutes les techniques
technologie de d'économie d'énergie
panneaux Solair je sais pas les pompes à
chaleur ce genre de choses et si vous
voulez en savoir plus sur le Solar
Decathlon restez bien évidemment sur
TVfil puisque vous savez nous suivons
cette compétition le prochain numéro
d'équilibre le magazine de
l'environnement avec Olivier Manis calco
sera entièrement dédié à cette
compétition l'occasion de se rattraper
puisque ce soir nous devions vous
proposer un entretien avec Pascal rouais
le directeur de la compétition qui
visiblement a été retenu ailleurs et qui
n'a pas pu rejoindre nos locaux entre
versaill et aiguill encour la
circulation est parfois difficile nous
parlions en tout cas tout à l'heure de
la colline d'éencour cette colline
autrefois baptisé colline de la revanche
qui devrait peut-être accueillir dans le
futur une station de ski a pour le
moment été le terrain de jeu de la
police nationale la dernière édition du
vetathlon vient de s'y tenir Olivier
maniskelco et lodim moine 3,8 km de
course à pied 18 de VTT plus 2,6 km à
nouveau en basket pour terminer le tout
sous un un soleil de plomb pour cette
nouvelle édition au bassin de la
Courance à repas le vetathlon de
l'amical police hlancour rambouillé n'a
pas ménagé les organisme à l'image du
visage marqué du vainqueur Vincent
Poirier qui a 6 minutes près égalé le
record de la course 1hure 11 minutes
tout de même pour le policier habitué
des triathlon ça s'est bien passé
première course à pied c'est plutôt mon
domaine donc j'ai pris un peu d'avance
et à VTT j'étais bien j'étais costaud
dans les bosses ça allit assz dur quand
même quand même assez chaud il y av pas
trop d'air à part la partie AVTT où
c'est en forêt donc ça va ça passe mais
à pied c'est c'est c'est vraiment dur si
la chaleur étouffante augmenta la
difficulté du parcours les coureurs
pouvaient compter sur le soutien du
public seul point noir dans cette
journée cette 10e édition du vetathlon
est aussi la dernière la course souffre
de la diminution du nombre de
participants en moyenne une centaine sur
les neu premières éditions les coureurs
étaient environ 40 cette année la faute
également à une nouvelle réglementation
en forêt l'ofice national les forêts
donc interdit les courses de VTT euh
chronométré donc bon il restructurent un
petit peu chez eux et forcément ben nous
on applique à la lettre les conditions
et le code des forêts donc l'année
prochaine on ne pourra plus faire de
courses VTT au sein des forêts
dominienes un nouveau challenge sportif
pourrait voir le jour dès l'an prochain
remplacement du vetathlon du tir combiné
à de la natation et de la course le
projet est déjà dans les
cartons cette édition du 78 lactue est
maintenant terminée vous pouvez la
retrouver sur notre site Internet grâce
au replay vos commentaires sur les
réseaux sociaux vous connaissez le
hashtag sur Twitter c'est 78 actu et
votre soirée sur TVfil c'est avec
aurellia debicii pour une nouvelle
édition de kiosque le magazine de la
culture excellente soirée donc et à
demain